ضجه واسعه اثارها اعلان وزير الخارجيه
الروسي بان مجموعه فاجنر القتاليه متاحه
للمشاركه في المعارك الدائره حاليا في
السودان لكن لم يوضح في تصريحاتهما اذا
كان لهذه المجموعه عناصر على الاراضي
السودانيه يشاركون في القتال مع الجيش
بقياده البرهان او قوات الدعم السريع
بقياده حميدتي وفيما اعربت الخارجيه
الامريكيه عن قلقها البالغ لتورط المجموعه
في حرب السودان خصوصا ان الغرب يتهمها
بتجنيد مرتزقه حول العالم وارتكاب جرائم
حرب في دول عده اكد رئيس فاجنر عدم وجود
اي مقاتل تابعا لمجموعته داخل الاراضي
السودانيه منذ اكثر من عامين نافيا تورط
مسلحيه في الصراع السوداني الحالي ومع كل
هذه المعلومات يطرح رواد مواقع التواصل
سؤالا هل تقاتل فاجنر في السودان بشكل سري